und jetzt das heute schon mal
mit gundula gause und christian sievers
guten abend hinein manchmal reicht eine
kurze eilmeldung um die fast schon
absurde verfahren haid einer situation
ganz klar zu machen
heute mittag berichtet ein britischer
sender nach einem kurzen gespräch mit
dem präsidenten der türkei recep tayyip
erdogan lena ein treffen mit dem
amerikanischen vize präsidenten ab und
sofort läuft ein film im hirn man stellt
sich vor wie mike pence in erfolgs
number two über ankara kreist auf
vermittlungsmission seines präsidenten
in sachen syrien offensive und nicht
landen darf oder im hotel warten muss
ist der rückflug geht dann stellt die
türkei klar erdogan wird pence doch
treffen
aber wer denkt da seien zugeständnisse
zu erwarten wird enttäuscht recep tayyip
erdogan findet er habe grünes licht aus
washington bekommen für seinen angriff
auf die kurden in syrien
und er denkt nicht daran den zu stoppen
glück war der ton wird immer schriller
breitseiten praktisch im stundentakt
präsident trump und seine amtskollegin
ankara lassen die welt teilhaben an
ihrer gegenseitigen abneigung
ich habe erdogan ihr grünes licht
gegeben für diese militärintervention
ganz im gegenteil wenn sie den scharfen
brief sehen würden den ich ihm nach dem
telefonat geschickt habe erdogan so der
eindruck macht sich über den zuweilen
wieder auftretenden mann in washington
inzwischen öffentlich lustig bisher habe
er noch versucht die tweets zu lesen
inzwischen sein dass zu viel das könne
man nicht mehr verfolgen die
ankündigungen aus washington man werde
führende minister und erdogans familie
auf eine sanktionsliste setzen parierte
erlassen
die art wie der us-kongress über meine
minister und meine familie diskutiert
ist sehr respektlos
wir müssen das erst einmal bewerten und
dann sehen ob ich wie geplant nach
washington reisen
ermittlungen eines new yorker richters
gegen die staatsnahe türkische halkbank
die iran-sanktionen unterlaufen und
milliardengeschäfte für teheran
abgewickelt haben soll
daran sieht man wie emotional die ganze
sache wird der fall war doch längst zu
den akten gelegt ankara bleiben trumps
erratische lageeinschätzungen nicht
verborgen
etwa wenn er beklagt dass die kurden
nicht bei der landung in der normandie
1944 dabei waren oder empfiehlt russland
china oder napoleon solle die kurden
beschützen
die kunden ziehen von der grenze ab
syrien übernimmt ich wünsche ihnen viel
glück
also für die vereinigten staaten ist die
situation an dieser grenze strategisch
brillant bei soviel analytischer schärfe
seines gegenübers sieht sich erdogan in
der komfortablen lage auf vor schenkten
keine rücksicht mehr nehmen zu müssen
mit stehenden ovationen wurde der
türkische fällte er heute von seiner
parlamentsfraktion empfangen
zuvor hatte er noch europas und
deutschlands außenminister wegen der
waffenexport einschränkungen als
politischen amateur verspottet
us-vizepräsident pence will er morgen
empfangen zu verhandeln gibt es aber
nichts
[Applaus]
unser vorschlag für ein ende der
offensive ist alle terroristen legen
ihre waffen nieder und verlassen das ist
heute abend die sicherheitszone das
kommt beim volk gut an die wahrheit in
syrien ist für erdogan und seine nato
armee weitaus komplizierter denn sein
neuer freund putin entscheidet wer
welcher stück vom syrischen kuchen
bekommt
und bei uns in europa das hier
großbritannien hat seit heute einen
neuen fernsehsender und der startet mit
einem großen versprechen keine
nachrichten die irgend etwas mit dem
brand zu tun haben
die verantwortlichen sprechen von einem
gewagten ansatz sie haben herausgefunden
dass viele zuschauer frustriert sind von
dem thema und gerne mal eine pause
hätten
wer sky news dragset free guckt wird
deshalb auch nicht erfahren dass es sich
jetzt tatsächlich etwas tut beim rexit
das nachrichtenwert hat auch wenn wohl
jeder der sich mit dem ewigen hin und
her intensiv beschäftigt so was wie exit
frust kennt anne gellinek guten abend
nach brüssel es soll ein vertrag fertig
sein
was steht da drin oder vielleicht erst
mal gibt's diesen vertrag überhaupt
nein es gibt ihn noch nicht der
unterhändler der eu michel barnier hat
bis vor einer dreiviertelstunde mit den
botschaftern der 27 anderen
mitgliedstaaten zusammen gesessen hat
sie gebrieft und hat ihnen gesagt dass
er noch weiter verhandeln wird es sind
zwar fast alle großen stolpersteine
dieser gespräche gelöst man dreht sich
jetzt wirklich noch ums kleingedruckte
zum beispiel um die komplizierte frage
der mehrwertsteuersätze auf der irischen
insel aber der ganz große wurf ist noch
nicht da der deal ist noch nicht fertig
und insofern müssen wir noch ein
bisschen abwarten
als zweite problem ist offenbar dass die
verhandler sich zwar einig sind die
britischen und die europäischen das aber
boris johnson seine politische
zustimmung zu diesem vertrag noch nicht
gegeben hat und das liegt natürlich
daran dass er sich in britisch noch
abstimmen muss dass er noch nicht weiß
ob die hardliner der praxis und die
nordirische die op tatsächlich hinter
diesem vertrag stehen werden falls
gehören morgen wieder mehr
auch in dieser sendung an herzlichen
dank für die moment nach brüssel
düsseldorf wird ab heute zum zentrum der
weltweiten plastikindustrie und es ist
nicht ganz sicher ob düsseldorf sich
darüber uneingeschränkt freuen
damit ist schon mal der enormen spagat
beschrieben den wir ihnen jetzt zeigen
auf der einen seite eine branche die
sich und ihre umsatzzahlen feiert die
kunststoffmesse
in düsseldorf ist die weltgrößte
leistungsschau für das produkt des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts
schlechthin
die plastik produktion hat sich in den
vergangenen jahren mehr als verdoppelt
das ergebnis sehen wir und dass es die
andere seite in unseren ozeanen auf
unseren müll bergen und in unseren
körpern der kassenschlager kunststoff
und das plastik problem während immer
mehr verbraucher sich bemühen um
irgendwie um strohhalme und
eingeschweißte gurken herumzukommen geht
die industrie davon aus dass sich der
weltweite verbrauch bis 2030 noch mal
mehr als verdoppelt wie lange lässt sich
dieser spagat noch aushalten dominik
müller roussel berichtet um 8
plastikbecher herzustellen braucht diese
spritzgießmaschine nur wenige sekunden
nachschub für die schier unendliche
verpackungsindustrie
doch das neue das granulat für die
becher besteht zumindest zu einem teil
aus recyceltem kunststoff recycling das
thema das das image der branche retten
soll
jahrzehntelang war die welt der
kunststoffhersteller heil nun gelten sie
als schmutzfinken als umweltzerstörer
allerhöchste zeit um zu spenden
kunststoff ist ein werkstoff und ist
auch ein wertstoff das heißt
geschlossene kreisläufe bedeuten
produkte nach ihrer benutzung wieder
zurückzuführen zu bearbeiten und zu
verarbeiten und neuer produkte
herzustellen
doch plastikmüll zu recyceln ist nicht
einfach reinigen schreddern und vor
allem müssen die unterschiedlichen
kunststoffe getrennt und sortiert werden
denn der markt verlangt nach sauberem
material diese prozesse sind aufwendig
und teuer
ich würde sagen das grundsätzliche
problem ist das recycling zusätzlicher
prozessschritt ist und solange wir halt
neue kunststoff günstiger ist als
recyceltes material wird es doch schwer
werden das in größerem maße zu tun
ein systemfehler unsere lange keine
verbindlichen quoten bestehen recycelter
kunststoffe einzusetzen werden sich die
bemühungen der hersteller im rahmen
halten
bemängelt sogar die branche selbst den
recycling verpackungen aus sogenanntem
rezitierten plastik sind eben teurer
der markt wird es nicht richten dieses
system wird nicht funktionieren indem
man es einfach nur dem verbraucher über
lässt der wird nicht am im supermarkt
entscheiden ich nehme jetzt nur
rezitierte produkte war das gar nicht
weiß ja kann es gar nicht sehen und
sieht nur dieses eine produkt ist teurer
als andere obwohl der inhalt der gleiche
ist also brauchen wir klare gesetzliche
vorgaben die für alle gelten und zwar
nicht nur in deutschland sondern
europaweit
vorhaben wie viel recycelten kunststoff
künftig eine verpackung enthalten muss
der verbrauch von plastik packungen hat
sich übrigens in den letzten 20 jahren
verdoppelt und nur 20 prozent des
deutschen plastikmülls gehen bislang
wieder in den kreislauf zurück wenn sie
sich angucken anteil der väter
materialien liegt die niederlande
deutlich vor uns wenn man bei den zielen
guckt haben andere länder ganz klare
vermeidungs ziele und wir halt immer
noch die klassischen recycling ziele
also auf ganz vielen ebenen haben viele
leute schlaue ideen und ich finde es ist
an der zeit dass wir auch in deutschland
überlegen wie wir an diesem
zukunftsthema profitieren und
partizipieren können vielleicht wird
plastik so zu einem etwas
umweltverträglicheren stoff die branche
versucht zukunftsfähig zu werden und zu
bleiben noch beim brennpunkt
umweltpolitik da soll es jetzt extra
schnell gehen den bundestag und
bundesrat findet die regierungskoalition
die heute konkrete steuerbeschlüsse im
kabinett klar gemacht hat für mehr
klimaschutz
schon gleich anfang nächsten jahres
werden wir das merken bahn fahren soll
billiger werden und fliegen dann ab
april teurer details von cornelia
schiemenz es war bislang die längste
koalitions nacht und an deren ende stand
am 20 september das große klimapaket der
großen koalition
und nun soll alles ganz schnell gehen im
eiltempo werden die einzelnen maßnahmen
in gesetzes paketen verschnürt heute
neue steuerregeln im verkehrssektor
verziert mit ganz großen worten
ein paket das dazu beitragen wird dass
der klimawandel aufgehalten werden
den klimawandel aufhalten das heißt für
die koalition ran ans fliegen aber nur
ein bisschen
ab april soll fliegen teurer werden die
luftverkehrssteuer steigt abhängig von
der entfernung bis 2500 kilometer werden
13 euro fällig bis 6000 kilometer 33 und
für noch größere entfernungen fast 60
das ist also die deutlichste handlung um
sicherzustellen dass mehr andere
verkehrsmittel insbesondere die bahnen
genutzt wird für innerdeutsche strecken
ich glaube ich nicht dass diese geringe
auswirkungen die es auf den ticketpreis
hat irgend einen anreiz von
nennenswerten ausmaß schafft dass die
leute nicht mehr fliegen sondern
stattdessen mit der bahn fahren
die bundesregierung spricht von einer
lenkungswirkung weg vom flieger hin zur
bahn
deshalb wird bahnfahren billiger ab
januar sinkt die mehrwertsteuer auf
fernverkehrs tickets von 19 auf 7
prozent
die bahn verspricht im gegenzug die
ticketpreise um etwa zehn prozent zu
senken gesetzlich verpflichtet wird sie
dazu nicht das recht auf gar keinen fall
bahntickets müssen nicht nur deutlich
preiswerter werden sondern die bahn muss
ausgebaut werden es sind ja in den
letzten jahren tausende kilometer
strecken stillgelegt werden und
verantwortlich diese strecken brauchen
wir ebenfalls beschlossen eine co2
bepreisung dadurch werden heizöl diesel
und benzin deutlich teurer
im gegenzug sollen die bürger und
bürgerinnen bei der pendlerpauschale
entlastet werden
ab 2021 für fünf jahre ab dem 21
kilometer steigt die pendlerpauschale
von 30 auf 35 cent wer wenig verdient
und deshalb wenig steuern zahlt soll
eine mobilitäts prämie aufs konto
erhalten die co2 bepreisung ist
beschlossen die fdp spricht vom klima
aktivismus
die union hat im wahlkampf immer groß
getönt dass sie eben keine
steuererhöhungen will jetzt ist das
einzige was heute im großen teil
beschlossen wird und das der falsche weg
nachdem es monate gedauert hatte bis das
klimapaket stand drückt die regierung
jetzt aufs tempo bereits nächste woche
sollen die gesetzentwürfe im bundestag
beraten werden
und jetzt gucken wir auf weitere
wichtige nachrichten von heute und die
hat gundula gebündelt die vom
bundesverfassungsgericht geforderte
reform der grundsteuer kann am freitag
im bundestag beschlossen werden
nach langem ringen um details wollen fdp
und grüne mit der regierungskoalition
für die notwendige grundgesetzänderung
stimmen
der kompromiss sieht vor dass die länder
bei der geforderten neuberechnung eigene
methoden anwenden dürfen ob die
hausbesitzer im einzelnen stärker oder
geringer belastet werden ist noch unklar
die kommunen müssen die neuen hebesätze
festlegen die grundsteuer bringt ihnen
jährlich 14 milliarden euro ein
deutschland und frankreich haben sich
beim deutsch französischen ministerrat
nach langem streit auf regeln für
rüstungsexporte verständigt so sollen
nun beispielsweise französische
rüstungsexporte nicht mehr blockiert
werden
wenn ein bestimmter anteil an deutschen
bauteilen nicht überschritten wird
zuvor hatten kanzlerin merkel und
frankreichs präsident marco den
flugzeugbauer airbus besucht am
hauptsitz in toulouse besichtigten sie
eine werkshalle in der das
langstreckenflugzeug a350 gefertigt wird
der europäische luftfahrt- und
rüstungskonzern gilt als musterbeispiel
deutsch-französische industriepolitik
die neue eu kommissionspräsident in von
der leyen wird nicht wie geplant am
ersten november die arbeit mit ihrer
neuen kommission aufnehmen können
die spitze des eu-parlaments kippte den
bisherigen zeitplan und fordert einen
kommissions- start nun am ersten
dezember hintergrund ist das scheitern
von drei kandidaten für die kommission
im nominierungsverfahren frankreich
rumänien und ungarn müssen nun neue
kandidaten präsentieren
im zusammenhang mit dem terroranschlag
in halle hat die polizei in
mönchengladbach die wohnung zweier
männer durchsucht
die staatsanwaltschaft wirft ihnen vor
nach dem antisemitischen und
rechtsextrem terroristischen angriff das
sogenannte manifest des mutmaßlichen
täters im internet verbreitet zu haben
gegen die 26 und 28 jahre alten männer
werde wegen volksverhetzung ermittelt
die katalanische unabhängigkeitsbewegung
hat ihre proteste gegen die hohen
gefängnisstrafen für mehrere
separatistenführer fortgesetzt in fünf
städten der region im nordosten spaniens
beteiligten sich tausende an den
sogenannten menschen für die freiheit
sie sollen am freitag in barcelona
ankommen vergangene nacht gab es dort
erneut heftige ausschreitungen die
polizei nahm 51 demonstranten fest mehr
als 125 wurden verletzt
spaniens regierung verurteilte die
krawalle und will mit aller
entschlossenheit gegen die
unabhängigkeit befürworte vorgehen das
hier ist das parlament von hongkong
werden sie vielleicht nicht kennen wir
gucken da auch nicht alle tage hin
und das hat gründe es ist ein spezielles
parlament das nicht wirklich
demokratisch zusammengesetzt ist was
sich auch in der tatsache zeigt dass es
heute zum ersten mal zusammengekommen
ist seit der beispiellosen protestwelle
die hongkong seit immerhin vier monaten
den atem hält die bewegung von millionen
menschen in hongkong die ja gerade mehr
demokratie fordern
es war alles andere als eine normale
sitzung stephanie schöneborn berichtet
carol m die regierungschefin hongkongs
ist für die meisten menschen vor allem
eines der verlängerte am pik so sehen es
auch diese parlamentarier die ihr
entgegen rufen carol m muss zurücktreten
die regierungschefin ist die zentrale
figur in einem system das nur zum teil
demokratisch ist terry lemm als
regierungschefin wird von peking
vorgeschlagen
und sie setzt ihre regierung nur in
absprache mit pickel zusammen aus der
auswahl von personen zb die
spitzenpositionen in der
sonderverwaltungszone hongkong besetzen
geht hervor dass in pekings augen
loyalität und die bereitschaft pekings
linie einzuhalten wichtiger zu sein
scheinen als glaubwürdigkeit fähigkeit
und ansehen in der gemeinschaft von auch
das parlament ist in hongkong anders 70
abgeordnete gibt es doch wird nur eine
hälfte gewählt die andere wird bestimmt
vor allem aus berufsverbänden unter
pekings einfluss also nutzen die rund 20
pro demokratischen parlamentarier das
einzige mittel das sie haben sie
protestieren wollen die
regierungserklärung carril ems
verhindern
mit einem teiler von carol m kommt über
die ersten paar sätze nicht hinaus immer
wieder gibt es laute zwischenrufe die tv
übertragung wird zweimal unterbrochen
ein abgeordneter tritt die maske von
jean ping & carry nennt gibt auf ihre
regierungserklärung wird sie nicht im
parlament verlesen sondern abgeschottet
per video nachricht wendet sie sich an
die bevölkerung
wir werden uns an ein land zwei systeme
halten und die durch das grundgesetz
festgelegten rechte und freiheiten
schützen aber handlungen die für die
unabhängigkeit funken und die
souveränität sicherheit und entwicklungs
interessen des landes bedrohen
das werden wir nicht tolerieren
unabhängigkeit genau dafür demonstrieren
die menschen seit monaten in hongkong
auch heute die regierungserklärung wirbt
für sie wie eine farce mehr als 70
prozent der hongkonger wollen ihre
forderung erfüllt haben und sie fordern
dass carol m zurücktritt
das will die mehrheit sowas kann man
einfach nicht machen sich hier
hinstellen als sei nichts gewesen nun
alles einfach unter den teppich kehren
bei einer anschließenden pressekonferenz
stellt carol m sich dann den fragen zu
ihrer regierungserklärung die
wohnungsnutzer beseitigt werden die
gesundheitsversorgung garantiert vor
allem aber müsse hongkong wieder zur
normalität zurückfinden
die unabhängigkeit hongkongs von china
aber das betont sie auch hier gehören
nicht dazu
jeder reporter kennt das schnell
hinfahren zu einer geschichte für die
nachrichten und schnell wieder weg das
es selten befriedigend für eine region
gut kennt und ihre menschen hat bessere
information einfache regel wie wäre es
also wenn die reporter gleich an den
orten über die sie berichten längere
zeit leben zdf in altenburg ist das
aktuelle projekt dass diese idee umsetzt
altenburg kennen scart fans und
überhaupt kartenspieler zumindest vom
namen matthias kubica und kameramann
niklas grunwald leben im moment in
altenburg und sie zeigen uns vor der
wichtigen thüringen war eine besondere
facette dieses bundeslandes das im
ostdeutschen vergleich ziemlich oft in
der spitzengruppe ist zum beispiel wenn
es um wenig arbeitslose geht trotzdem
fühlen sich viele im östlichsten zipfel
thüringens ein bisschen vergessen von
der fernen landeshauptstadt spiele für
die welt die altenburger
spielkartenfabrik hat damals die
treuhand überlebt dank investoren aus
dem westen
inzwischen gehört das
traditionsunternehmen einer belgischen
firma 270 jobs ein verlässliches wenn
auch kleines wirtschaftliches glanzlicht
wir steuern alle aktivitäten hier von
altenburg aus das heißt
es gibt keine verlängere der werbung wir
sind die werkbank altenburg eine
kleinstadt mit traumkulisse
schlosstheater keine bombenschäden die
wende war der große bruch 1989 lebten
51.000 menschen hier heute sind es fast
20.000 weniger der abbau ost sitzt vor
allem vielen älteren in den knochen
ja es sind viele arbeitslos geworden
müssen arbeitsförderungsgesellschaft
gekommen und umschulung gemacht fehlt
heute die industrie bei uns gefehlt die
ganze generation die 1990
er kämpft dafür dass altenburg wieder
aufsteigt oberbürgermeister andré
neumann spielräume sind allerdings in
die westdeutsche partnerstadt offenburg
zum beispiel nehmen 85 millionen euro
gewerbesteuer ein
altenburg 7 die gewerbesteuer gehört
reformiert
wenn ich hier firmen habe wo tragen und
leute zuhören und leute arbeiten das
ergebnis aber der haupt gewerbesteuer
anteil in stuttgart landeten opel
holding sitzt dann habe altenburg eben
nichts davon
andré neumann kämpft auch um junge leute
für seine stadt alles großstadt
es ist eine riesen chance für diese
stadt eine wohnstadt für familien zu
werden vor allem leipzig wird immer
voller und teurer acht euro miete pro
quadratmeter im schnitt viele zieht es
raus mit der neuen s bahn geht das
schnell 38 minuten von der leipziger
city bis altenburg in den preiswerten
speckgürtel wo man für fünf euro den
quadratmeter wohnt immer mehr pendeln
sowie carla däne
sie ist lehrerin in leipzig dort fand
sie für sich und ihre familie keine
passende wohnung mehr in altenburg leben
sie nun auf dem schloss sie lieben das
kleinstadtleben
letzterer ist für mich war gerade das
argument die kinder großzuziehen fast
das entscheidende mit dass ich glaube
die werden in einer übersichtlichen
stadt auch übersichtlicher groß manche
stadt im westen würde sich alle zehn
finger danach lecken nach dieser
altbausubstanz nach den strukturen die
es hier noch gibt ihre wohnung in
märchenhafter kulisse haben sie selbst
renoviert vieles andere in altenburg
wartet noch darauf wach geküsst zu
werden und jetzt noch mal gut mit
meldungen aus der wirtschaft
da ließ eine panne beim sportwagenbauer
porsche heute aufhorchen
die produktion stand vorübergehend still
im stammwerk stuttgart zuffenhausen und
im wert leipzig in einer zeit in der
unternehmen auf produktion 4.0 setzen
auf die digitalisierung ihrer
produktionssysteme sina mainitz da fragt
sich wie ein so kapitaler serverausfall
zu erklären ist er die autofertigung
wird immer digitaler und vernetzter
salopp gesagt macht der roboter
inzwischen mehr arbeit als der kfz
mechatroniker
damit werden fertigungssysteme für
fahrzeuge aber auch immer anfälliger für
fehler
so etwas ist offenbar bei porsche
passiert mehr als 200 server fielen in
den werken zu hausen und leipzig aus die
produktionsstopps für einige stunden ein
fehlerhafter datenspeicher habe sich auf
verschiedene bereiche in logistik und
produktion ausgewirkt heisst es weltweit
läuft immer mehr in der autoindustrie
über die vernetzte robotik auf platz
eins dieser fertigung steht japan
gefolgt von südkorea und den usa auf
platz vier ist deutschland wenn auch
europaweit führend
porsche will den produktionsrückstand
schnellstmöglich aufholen wirtschaftlich
gesehen erwartet porsche nach eigenen
angaben keinen nachhaltigen schaden
das liegt wohl auch daran dass der
autobauer nur verhältnismäßig kleine
stückzahlen produziert eine versicherung
für produktionsausfälle dieser art gibt
es wohl nicht man habe sich aber
vertraglich bei dem systemlieferanten
abgesichert heißt es bei porsche
bei einem serverausfall eines
unternehmens dieser größenordnung wird
auch häufig eine cyber-attacke als
ursache vermutet doch ein hacker angriff
von außen auf die produktion bei porsche
entschieden zurück
dennoch die herausforderung der
industrie 4.0 bleibt der umgang mit
sicherheit vielen dank seiner kaputt die
sogenannten grünen damen und herren
haben zu ihrem 50 jährigen
gründungsjubiläum mehr unterstützung für
ihre ehrenamtliche arbeit in
krankenhäusern und altenheimen gefordert
die mitgliedsbeiträge reicht nicht für
die verwaltung und organisation der
bundesweit 8000 frauen und männer die
sich freiwillig in krankenhäusern und
heimen um patienten kümmern
bundespräsident steinmeier würdigte die
ehrenamtler als leuchtendes vorbild
die gewinnzahlen vom lotto am mittwoch
lauten diesmal wie immer ohne gewähr
5 912 17 31 38 superzahl 8 weitere
gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de und im zdf
text ein mysteriöser fall beschäftigt
die niederlande
dort sollen auf einem abgelegenen
bauernhof ein vater und seine fünf
inzwischen erwachsenen kinder seit 2010
in vollkommener isolation gelebt haben
am montag hatte sich der älteste sohn in
einem gasthaus gemeldet und um hilfe
gebeten
dabei soll er einen verwirrten eindruck
gemacht haben ob die familie freiwillig
auf dem bauernhof lebte ist unklar
der mieter ein 58 jähriger mann aus
österreich wurde inzwischen festgenommen
er wird der freiheitsberaubung
verdächtigt unsere welt ist schön und
zum verzweifeln oft beides zugleich
das zeigt sich auch in einer sendung wie
dieser das zeigt sich nicht nur in dem
was wir menschen tun
das zeigen die gewinner von einem der
renommiertesten preise den mann als
naturfotograf bekommen kann wildlife
photographer of the year 48.000
fotografen aus 100 länder haben
mitgemacht 19 kategorien und alle
facetten des tierreichs pure schönheit
atemberaubende blickwinkel immer wieder
der kampf ums überleben
wir berichten seit tagen intensiv über
die verheerende situation der menschen
im norden von syrien zwei kolleginnen
und ich waren dort kurz vor dem
türkischen angriff wir haben kleine
kinder gesehen die erst ein paar wochen
auf dieser welt sind und bereits mit dem
tod kämpfen und mutige mediziner die
ihre eigene sicherheit aufs spiel setzen
um ihnen zu helfen
das ist eine geschichte über liebe und
hass mit gefühl und gewalt in einer
region die mal wiege der menschheit war
wir nehmen sie mit auf diese reise
gleich im auslandsjournal mit anti
pieper einfach dranbleiben und wir seien
bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren von
jetzt an geht's bergab mit den
temperaturen zum beispiel in freiburg im
breisgau
bis zum monatsende liegen die
höchsttemperaturen nämlich nur noch so
um die 13 grad und auch die temperaturen
sinken die liegen danach so um die 7
grad und damit wird auch der unterschied
zwischen höchst und tiefsttemperaturen
bis zum monatsende immer geringer das
ist jetzt aber nicht so wirklich kalt
wird
das liegt einfach daran dass wir immer
noch die gleiche wetterlage haben das
tief fielen nämlich über großbritannien
zieht bis mitte nächster woche einfach
nur weiter richtung süden und so
verbleiben wer in der milden
südwestströmung das bedeutet recht hohe
temperaturen und regen heute nacht
regnet es entlang den küsten von ost und
nordsee und zwischen dem emsland und dem
oberrhein
sonst ist es häufig trocken und an der
donau bildet sich nebel
am alpenrand wird es richtig klar und
dort genauso wie in niederbayern sinken
die temperaturen auf 3 bis 2 grad dort
droht also bodenfrost deutlich milder
bleibt die nacht zwischen der elbe und
dem niederrhein mit 14 bis zwölf grad
die höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
dann meist bei 14 bis 17 grad aber hier
zwischen sachsen und baden württemberg
und südöstlich davon geht auf 16 bis 20
grad drauf denn da scheint am meisten
die sonne zwischen der muse und der
ostsee ist es dagegen meist trüb es
regnet leicht an der nordsee kommt die
sonne zum vorschein und eher wechselhaft
und mild geht es eben auch in den
nächsten tagen weiter schönen abend noch